ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt und meine lieben freunde was war
das gestern bitte für ein riesiger fan
von mir bei der episode minecraft mit
luca ich habe gestern ja dieses haus
hier gebaut und wenn doch eigentlich
schon ein bisschen vorangekommen
allerdings hat meine face kemnat einfach
probleme gehabt weshalb ich das dann
gestern nach kommentieren musste was
sage ich überhaupt wahrscheinlich eh
alle gesehen das video ist trotzdem in
die trends auf platz fünf gekommen also
danke für euren support hallo schwein
perfect dark motivierenden worte brauche
ich auf jeden fall für die heutige
episode denn ich habe mir wieder extrem
viel diese nummer antike schrott alter
jetzt endlich mal wurde mir auch und in
die kommentare geschrieben luca du musst
diesen antiken schrott einfach mal in
deinen ofen packen und dann bekommst du
da die nutzbaren raus ich habe nur
kohleblöcke mittig tausch mal kurz ein
gegen neuen kohle- und verbrauchen wir
nicht so viel packe ich jetzt mal kohle
rein und den antiken schrott es
funktioniert auf jeden fall das heißt
meine lieben freunde wir bekommen jetzt
aus dem antiken schrott das beste
material in minecraft und zwar das sieht
aus wie eine scheiße wir haben für die
heutige episode allerdings wieder extrem
viel auf der to-do-liste und dürfen
dementsprechend überhaupt keine zeit
verlieren zunächst einmal werde ich hier
vorne
das komplette feld ein wenig neu
bepflanzen das ist ja wieder gewachsen
und wir werden auch das weizen direkt
nehmen um daraus brot zu machen ich weiß
nicht ob ich hier vorne sogar noch was
drin habe genau ich hab noch 17 brot und
hier auch noch ein bisschen weizen
dann werde ich das jetzt einfach mal
nehmen zum einer werkbank hinten im
willicher auslaufen oder lächelt wie
schon bei yuan was geht
leute es tut mir leid ich kann es für
ich weiß gar nicht warum haben wir eine
schildkröte lunz am see ins meer
viel spaß beim hier rein und werde ganz
kurz an die werkbank gehen denn wir
benötigen noch mehr brot der ein oder
andere extrem erfahrene minecraft
spieler weiß schon was ich machen möchte
denn ich möchte mal wieder auf unsere
villiger insel hier vorne gehen und die
village sich vermehren lassen damit die
kinder bekommen nicht weil eines unserer
kinder glaube ich eventuell getötet
wurde ich weiß es nicht sieht echt süß
aus die mittlerweile mit dem feld ich
werde hier noch einen kompost anpacken
kann hier ist schon einer der andere
steht immer noch hier
irgendwie haben haben alle hier was
gegen mich ich weiß hier vorne jetzt
einfach mal brot hin dass heißt er holt
sich das und jetzt geht er nämlich zu
seinem kollegen
jetzt kannst du jetzt hier nicht
aussuchen
jetzt mach das ist die falsche richtung
meister hat herrn etwas setzt mit dem
anderen ist es halt auch das ding ich
hab halt leider mit ihm schon gehandelt
weshalb ich nicht mehr den beruf fischer
entziehen kann und der andere den haben
wir sogar nicht mal auf lehrlinge
sondern schon auf geselle den
bibliothekaren dem kann ich den beruf
auch nicht mehr entfernen allerdings
möchte ich unbedingt einen farmer haben
und dafür dass man auch und einen
kommentar geschrieben
muss ich wohl erstmal den räucherofen
hier abbauen die brauchen wir ihn er ist
reingegangen
ich frag mich hiermit kommt macht ihr
euer ding ich glaube die können sich
auch nur fahren wenn die dinge sinn wenn
ich nicht mehr mit dabei bin was macht
ich darf er nicht so viel ablenken
lassen meine lieben freunde ich möchte
jetzt erstmal direkt nicht mehr
angerufen
papa ich bin in der wohnung ich nehme
mir jetzt ein video auf aber das ist
jetzt in der stunde 40 ich glaube da
musste ich durch sein
ich werde mir hier vorne erstmal
goldbarren rausnehmen und aus diesem
goldbarren werde ich mir eine hose
machen denn die essenziell wichtig dafür
wenn wir in die hölle gehen damit uns
diese leute da nicht angreifen
dann werde ich mich jetzt auch mal kurz
ein bisschen vorbereiten
[Musik]
und meine damen und herren wir sind
bereits vor einem neuen ausflug in die
hölle
ich finde diese hölle hat wirklich immer
so ziemlich diese ganzen tür mit ich
hier schon hingestellt aber als ich ja
mal hoch gelaufen bin
die hölle hat immer seinen crazy
weiblich das liegt wahrscheinlich auch
daran dass ich das immer mit der musik
so ein bisschen verbinde
allerdings ist es echt crazy komponenten
ist das anders
es müssen wir irgendwann nochmal machen
dass sich mit der warzen angel mit
seiner sandra über die über die lager
aber diese leute hier greifen mich auf
jeden fall erstmal nicht an die tu mir
nichts von daher haben wir eigentlich
unsere ruhe erstmal ich bin in die
andere richtung schon in der gestrigen
folge gegangen wo es leider nicht auf
kuppen und pumbaa ich bin glaube ich gut
vorbereitet wie immer direkt ringkampf
zack zack zack zack tod alter so nämlich
so nämlich keine angst vor diesen
fächern haben luca auch nicht vor mir
hey wir sind nur hier aufgrund des
platzes ich werde keinen einzigen
goldbarren abbauen denn ich habe keine
lust mit den leuten müsst ihr mir
irgendwie
die sache ist dass hier vorne auf jeden
fall quarz ist in die andere richtung
bin ich immer auf mein gott
[Musik]
in die andere richtung bin ich im
gestrigen video schon gegangen das hatte
ja nur in der time labs gesehen
deswegen habe ich mich erst mal für
diese richtung ihren schieben würde
allerdings auch sagen dass sich hieraus
auch kurztrips mache weil ich wirklich
nur kratzer bauen werde
wenn allerdings irgendetwas krasses
passieren sollte werde ich euch auf die
aok nicht sterben da habe ich schon aber
lang geplant nicht sterben nicht sterben
drei hatten den weg und kann nicht
sterben
direkt ehrlich muss man sich einfach
hälfte der leben verloren
egal ob jetzt da aus dem ich gehe mal
kurz quartz farmen halbe stunde wurde
habe ich mal wieder einen kleinen witz
vorbereitet und zwar hält der lehrer im
unterricht zweier hoch dass eine es weiß
und das andere braun lehrer fragt die
schüler darauf hin was ist der
unterschied zwischen diesen beiden eiern
antwortet fritzchen das braune war im
urlaub
[Musik]
ich habe aber noch einen wird
vorbereitet und zwar deine mutter ist so
dumm die schüttet wasser über ihren pc
im internet so meine lieben freunde eine
halbe stunde habe ich jetzt quarz
gefahren davon ist auch noch was und ich
zeige euch mal ganz kurz mal ein
fortschritt weil ich nichts mehr
aufnehmen kann ich kann die hierzu 64
quarz blöcken machen das hier vorne kann
ich einpacken dann habe ich 64 bürger
dann habe ich quasi schon mal zwei
stacks ich habe auch eine menge großen
mitgenommen das kann ich auch direkt zu
großen blöcken machen dann muss ich auch
nicht so viel mit diesem von diesem
staub immer mitschleppen
allerdings brauchen wir wirklich noch
deutlich mehr ich habe mal so ein
bisschen respekt vor diesem gremmel
da freue ich mich immer nie so richtig
lang zu laufen deswegen habe ich mir
gerade so ein kleiner weg gebaut das
problem was ich einfach habe ist dass
ich nicht weiß
wo ich dann gelaufen bin ich glaube wir
sind ein bisschen verloren wir vorne
befindet sich wirklich über eine menge
quad da unten ist auch noch ein bisschen
was also ich glaube einfach ich werde
noch so lange quarz farben dass meine
spitzhacke also diese glück spitzhacke
unten seht ihr im inventar die diamant
spitzhacke ist die kurzform zerbrechen
ist und dann werde ich mich mal auf dem
rückweg begeben
ich bin meiner stunde und 40 minuten
kommen handwerker oder beim quad suchen
habe ich jetzt noch eine weitere von
diesem komischen funktionsteile nie
gefunden ich bin ganz ehrlich ich würde
da gerade extrem gern rein gehen die
sache ist allerdings dass ich auch schon
beim betreten des neckars gesagt habe
das einzige ziel hier geht die fahrt
suche und das ist das worauf ich nicht
konzentrieren wird und die vita schon
immer ein inventar
ich habe die spitzhacke bis aufs maximum
beziehungs-aus minimum montag runter
abgebaut ich bin einfach verdammt
nochmal level 37 hier vorne den quartz
nämlich auch noch mal eben mit sack und
pack und hier vorne einmal die blöcke
daran sieht man ja auch immer so ein
bisschen wie viel ich wirklich auch
abgebaut habe klar ich bin auch in viele
kämpfe geraten
allerdings kann das meiste wirklich
durch quartz abbauen und das wird er
auch wenn ich jetzt mal ganz kurz ihr
euch zeigen wie viele ich schon wieder
hiervon habe die kann ich jetzt immer
kurz zusammenpacken krieg hier noch
einige quartale sagte sack und hier auch
noch welche ich habe 12 3 1 halbs text
tatsächlich schon
wir brauchen zwar noch deutlich mehr für
das komplette strandvilla haus
allerdings ist das auf jeden fall schon
mal ein guter anfang wir müssen uns
jetzt halt irgendwie merken dass hier
vorne doch so eine bastion ruine ist die
sog
sogar mir ja keine ahnung wir uns das
jetzt merken sollen ich muss jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal den weg nach hause
finden ich lauf hier halt wirklich
gerade direkt neben dieser bastion links
her
ich weiß nicht ob ich da mal ganz kurzen
blick reinwerfen soll halogen mal weg
hier
oder ob das irgendwie zu viel verlangt
wäre ich habe keine ahnung da und nisse
comic opnet com macht es nicht wir
machen es nicht ich muss den weg
irgendwie zum portal suchen wenn ich
mich wie wenn ich mich nicht irre ist
dass das ist
es ist einfach die bastille mein gott du
kleiner sehe ich auch so das hier ist
einfach die bastion ruine neben meinem
portal also ich bin wohl anscheinend
glaube ich gar nicht mal so weit weg
deswegen werde ich hier vorne jetzt noch
mal eben kurz das quartz mitnehmen und
dann zum portal überlaufen und da sind
wir wieder in unserem portal angekommen
eigentlich müssen wir das ganze im
netter hier auch mal noch ein bisschen
schöner abbauen weil diese ganzen themen
wo ich mich immer hochbau sieht jetzt
auch nicht so unfassbar geil aus hier
vorne ist auch noch platz aber ich lasse
es jetzt wirklich einfach mal sein ich
habe genügend quarz mitgenommen um meine
lieben freunde wir befinden uns wieder
in meiner schöne ist dass soll uns
allerdings nicht von unserem strandvilla
traumhaus bauhaus projekt abhalten meine
lieben freunde von daher hoffe ich immer
gekonnt rüber und werde euch jetzt erst
mal zeigen was ich mir vorgestellt habe
beziehungsweise ihr wisst ja gleich was
ich mir vorgestellt habe ich habe seit
der letzten folge doch noch mal so ein
bisschen nach kommentiert dann
allerdings werde ich hier erst mal die
wände hochziehen denn ich möchte
wirklich und ich finde da bestehen auch
so moderne häuser das alles so ein
bisschen ja geräumiger ist als auf
unserer insel hier vorne werde ich das
ganze so machen und dann hier freilassen
zwei blöcke 1 2 hier wieder einen
hochziehen sechs blöcke hoch und dann
hier wieder einen frei lassen denn hier
kommen schwarze getönte fensterscheiben
hin
ich kann ich direkt mal machen
beziehungsweise meine lieben freunde was
wir jetzt erstmal machen sollten bei dem
regen ist eine schweigeminute
die verstorbene katze die verstorbene co
und alle verstorbenen pilz kühe werden
wirklich auf ewig in meinem herzen
bleiben und du hast diese leute hier
wird schon immer im inventar ich habe
einen angeschlagenen amboss mitgenommen
gerade aus meinem raum dahinter denn den
wollte ich hier irgendwo hinsetzen ich
weiß nicht wo man das machen könnte da
hab ich nehme hier einfach mal dass im
weg und sind jetzt einfach mal hier
drauf dann könnt ihr nämlich jetzt mal
ein paar sachen reparieren ich will dir
auf dauer alles hier rüber bringen
beziehungsweise ja auch noch ein paar
sachen immer im willicher häuschen
lagern denn die sind ja jetzt neben
ich werde erst mal ganz kurz meine glück
spitzhacke reparieren das kostet mich
jetzt zwar sieben erfahrung und wie
viele diamanten 23 nehme ich jetzt
einfach mal allerdings haben wir dann
das glück drei dings noch drauf wie
packe ich jetzt auch wieder ich hier
vorn einfach mal die kiste reinen
diamanten hier einig sollte das generell
mal eben einfach und dann bauen wir am
haus weiter also ich bin ich hab mal ein
bisschen rumgelaufen und wollten mal
gucken ob die hier schon kinder bekommen
haben ich bin halbes deck brot gegeben
das hier ist mein fischer lehrlinge also
das ist kein kind und er hier ist
bibliothekar geselle könnt ihr nicht mal
irgendwie jetzt man jetzt machbar glaubt
meine blut er klaut einfach meine blumen
was sind eher für die oper
ja okay dann ist in ordnung also meine
lieben freunde wir haben ein paar sachen
hier schon mitgenommen zum beispiel eine
truhe die wollte ich eigentlich noch da
hinten zu dem typen setzen
zusammen mit dem kompass damit den
pharma bekommen aber der hat ja nichts
gesagt werden wir keine kinder bekommen
ich hab mir das auf jeden fall so
vorgestellt dass ich hier beispielsweise
so eine kiste hinsetze und dann hier
vorne den komposter und dann kann der
typ halt ich weiß deswegen sollt ihr
kinder bekommen und dann könnt ihr
einfach hier so hingehen das hier
abbauen die melonen abbauen das abbauen
bam bam zack zack und hatten wir alles
hier schon in die kiste rheinbahn dann
hier vorne kompakt man auch mal die
pilze rein und so lange könnte das
einfach kann ich das so machen wenn die
rote bete hier ja schon mal machen das
wahrscheinlich zu machen
ja aber den kriegst du ja nicht ich habe
jetzt einfach noch mal neuen brot
getrachtet und schmeißt sie ihm jetzt
hier auch nochmal hin so sagt guck mal
er realisiert dass er gar keinen bock
auf das brot renners die brot brauchen
um sich zu vermehren
der garten ist nicht mehr drin wo hier
erzählt er draußen aber dann gebe ich
dem anderen hier vorne hier kommt sagt 9
brot er nimmt die neuen brot schaut die
sich an und jetzt gehst du zu deiner
frau
[Musik]
sehr gut nein er geht schon wieder auf
seine laterne war wir kümmern uns jetzt
allerdings erst mal eine sache die ich
schon lange aus steht und zwar hier
vorne das glas reinsetzen das musste ich
ja abbauen damit der willicher dadurch
kann hier vorne erwartet und das
schweinchen haben wir hier irgendwo noch
tintenfische die muss ich nämlich wieder
ich muss halt hinten fische töten weil
ich die inc sex brauche also diese
tintenfisch beute rucksäcke dank dinger
für den farbstoff damit ich mir damit
den grauen er wissen wir sehr hellgrauen
[Musik]
hat der tintenfisch da gerade seinen job
gemacht oder war das flipper wir haben
halt einmal in irgendeiner folge habe
ich meinen namensschild genommen und das
auf dem delfin gepackt und dem flipper
genannt und seitdem ist er weg um nach
rechts ist hat heißen delfin ich habe
jetzt irgendwie fähigkeit wieder
bekommen diese delfin fähigkeit keine
ahnung was man doch bringt aber ich
konzentriere mich erstmal auf die tinten
für schütz zack da habe ich auf jeden
fall schon mal einen stack war eine
andere tintenfische vorn als auch noch
einer der muss sich auch noch eben töten
zack kriege ich jetzt auch okay ich hab
zwar sportlich sind zwei delfine zu
einer von denen muss doch eine pause ein
das kann auch nicht sagen dass ich den
benennen und dann ist er einfach
abgecheckt ich will wissen ob das habe
er von dem flipper ist wie schwimmen wir
die ganze zeit nur von mir weg ich weiß
nicht ob es daran liegt dass er mir
einsteigen will
das ist nicht flipper
aber jetzt hab ich wieder diese delfin
fähigkeit uns des delfins bin ich
dadurch einfach schneller
ich glaube schon na ja wir sollten es
nicht so krass darauf konzentriere ich
brauche auf jeden fall noch einige
tintenfische weiß nicht wo sie gerade
sind würde aber sagen
die suche habe ich gerade auf jeden fall
noch gefunden das heißt ich sollte jetzt
auf jeden fall genügend farbstoff haben
um meine glasscheiben zu tönen 43 habe
ich schon ich müsste dafür allerdings
genau 64 haben von daher packe ich noch
43 durch +64 noch 21 da so von daher
würde ich sagen dass wir jetzt erstmal
allerdings noch einmal ganz kurz unser
obsidian nehmen und damit die wende hier
ein bisschen hoch ziehen denn das muss
alles gesungen
[Musik]
idiot ich muss ja die quarz blöcke noch
beraten von daher kräftig mir jetzt
einfach mal noch ein paar öffnen damit
das alles ein bisschen schneller geht
wir haben ja heute noch gar nichts
gebaut an unserem häuschen hier und dann
mache ich jetzt sogar nur 23 eben an
höfen sieht jetzt zwar nicht so schön
aus das aber erstmal nur ein mittel zum
zweck hier 64 stück rain hier vorne auch
noch mal 64 quarz blöcke rein ich möchte
das halt mit glatten quarz blöcken haben
in der gestrigen episode wie bereits
mehrfach erwähnt hatte ich ja face kein
probleme deswegen konnte ich das jetzt
nicht richtig erzählen bzw bisher gar
nicht so richtig bescheid dass hier sind
alles glatze quartz block nummer ganz
kurz zum vergleich wenn ich hier seinen
normalen kreis borken unter nebenstelle
seht ihr schon der hut sein land an der
seite ich weiß dass man jetzt
wahrscheinlich denkt man hier und da
hatten wir auch so eine kleine schlucht
entdeckt sogar direkt unter unserem haus
soll es aber nicht weiter jucken
die sache ist dass sich diese ganz
glatten quartz glocke ein bisschen
schöner finden und ich denke mir wenn
das hier schon so ein dauerprojekt sein
soll was wirklich viel zeit in anspruch
nimmt dann wollen es auch richtig machen
das werden wir denke ich heute nicht
mehr schaffen dann mit den wänden hoch
ziehen was sich allerdings auf jeden
fall noch machen wollte war und das kinn
laufzeit ich eigentlich jetzt relativ
easy noch eben hin dass ich einmal nach
der ganz hinten laufen denn da gab es ja
riesige berge und da waren wir auch in
der xxl höhen folge wo wir die mine
gefunden hatten und so da waren wir auch
dort am start
guck mal wie schön das aussieht wenn
sich da hinten die welt aufbaut ich
finde es generell so dass wir so viele
verschiedene inseln haben so hier vorne
halten das festland jedoch einzelne
kleine inseln hier vorne geht es weiter
hier dann unser modernes haus da unsere
insel bekommt er das wasserfall haus hin
darunter war sogar auch noch eine höhle
hatten wir in irgendeiner folge
festgehalten da wollten wir auch noch
rein auf jeden fall sind er diese
riesigen eisberge ich weiß nicht ob es
die sogar schon sind ja genau und ich
brauche eine menge kies der nicht
benötige noch eine menge beton
beton in minecraft ist ein blog wie
keramik oder wolle erhalten deko block
und sieht nun mal schön ausfindig vor
allem bei so modernen häusern
deswegen brauchen wir dafür eine menge
kies und eine menge sand vom daher
wollte ich ja noch eine menge kies
abbauen und was sich auch in der höhe
der episode entdeckt habt keine ahnung
was sich ab geht war das sich hinter
diesen kiez gebäuden bzw
hinter diesen kies bergen sind sehr mehr
dass sich dort hinter eine riesen blumen
landschaft entdeckt befindet hat von
daher würde ich allerdings erst mal
sagen ich nehme mir ein bisschen tief
mit ein und drei viertel sechs sollten
auf jeden fall reichen ich hab mir
hinten bei unseren kisten auch noch
eineinhalb stacks kies glaube ich drin
von daher sollte das denke ich passen
wir brauchen insgesamt 152 sand 152 kies
und 38 mal einen hellgrauen farbstoff
den wir aus margeriten bekommen sollte
sich übrigens mal nach rechts puck aber
erstmal eine riesen notiz die ich immer
vor den folgen
fertige damit wir nicht so komplett
planlos hier rumlaufen und ich habe auch
eine menge verpasst in minecraft was die
letzten jahre so geändert wurde
hier unten ist auf jeden fall so eine
blumen landschaft ich hab keine ahnung
wie das heißt dieses paradieses bionano
von den margeriten brauche ich insgesamt
38 stück da können uns also
[Musik]
wollen der unzen ruhen
ich werde hier generell denke ich mal
ein bisschen blumen mitnehmen das ist ja
unfassbar schön was sie alles rum steht
können wir auf jeden fall unsere insel
so ein bisschen die pflanzen
beziehungsweise auch vielleicht ein
bisschen zum grab hin packen
ich würde sagen ich möchte ich doch mal
ganz kurz eine allerletzte teilte heute
der danach muss ich die folge beenden
weil die handwerker gleich zu mir kommen
und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder
wenn ich die passende anzahl an
margeriten habe und wieder auf meiner
inseln kommt da schon anders hier für
schöne blumen sind es ist ja wahnsinn
[Musik]
meine lieben freunde wir sind wieder
angekommen was ist das rudel grad an
bord gewesen
so soll es dann irgendwann wirklich
komplett laufen mit der bahnstrecke dass
er dann einfach bis 8 ganz hinten fahren
können das ist jetzt gerade noch nicht
möglich gewesen
das dauert auch noch ein bisschen bis
wir das fertig kriegen ich kann auch
heute nichts weiteres von meiner
to-do-liste von meinem schwarzen bretter
unten streichen du kannst nicht schlaf
ist potsdam ii sind wir uns da das schaf
ist hier aber das sei kein monster
wo sollen denn die monster sein gibt es
niemand hier lassen sich schlafen legt
er jetzt stetig cannstatt minecraft ich
habe unfassbar viele blumen mitnehmen
können die kann ich jetzt erstmal alle
hier rein außer die margeriten die braut
zum färben ich hab auch noch einen
outlaw schale erhalten vom zombie darum
geschwommen ist genügend sand sollte ich
jetzt hoffentlich auch am start haben
von daher schaue mehr zum leben ganz
kurz wie viel wir jetzt schaffen hinten
an unserem gebäude die sache ist nämlich
warum stürzten jedoch das ist ein tag
den man verbrennen also ich zeige euch
das mal ganz gut wie das hier
funktionieren soll wir setzen uns herein
zack und dann ist es eher ein bisschen
langsamer
hier gibt es dann nicht mehr weiter weil
warum bist du so besser so okay aber
hier geht es nicht mehr weiter weil wir
noch keine schienen für haben wir noch
keine rechts- und fackel platziert das
kommt alles kein stress leute ich werde
mich jetzt erstmal darum bemühen dass
der quartz dings hier endlich mal fällig
ist bzw das bemühen das glas gefertigt
quarz braucht noch ein bisschen das
klingt auf jeden fall heute noch ein
bisschen hin zumindest waren jetzt zwar
die meiste zeit der folge hinten im netz
allerdings müssten musste das wirklich
sein einfach so wir haben hier die
glasscheiben 48 ad plus diese hier zack
können die jetzt einfach so hierhin
packen 8 stück und da packen jetzt den
farbstoff rein dann haben wir 64
schwarze glasscheiben den rest praktisch
schon mal eben kurz herein das braucht
nämlich erstmal nicht mehr und beim sand
gehen wir jetzt einfach mal so vor dass
ich
ich das hin ich weiß es nicht ich
verwende die margeriten erstmal in
farbstoff davon brauchen wir 38 stück
ich werde jetzt nicht alle direkt zur
farbstoff machen weil ich die margeriten
eigentlich auch ganz schön finde so ihr
kommt wieder hier rein und jetzt gucken
wir mal ich brauche 152 sand durch vier
sind das 38 das heißt zack zack zack das
kriegen wir auf jeden fall hin 38 so so
denkt aber ganz genau und dann hier auch
nochmal bamm bamm bamm und das schaffen
wir auf jeden fall braucht 38 und dann
noch von den margeriten von den 38
kriegen wir nämlich insgesamt dass hier
an hellgrauen trocken beton das sind
nämlich 300 stück das brauchen wir aber
auch denn das wird der boden hier von
sein wenn er trocken beton mit wasser in
berührung kommt dann wird das noch zu
normalen mit tonnen da müssen wir
nächsten folge auf jeden fall eine menge
dinge zu holen der menge erde oder stein
oder irgendwas was er darunter packen
können allerdings reicht das ihr auf
jeden fall erstmal aus erde und sand und
kies und keine ahnung wir brauchen
erstmal nicht mehr ich nehme jetzt
erstmal die glatten quartz blöcke und
zeige euch wie ich mir das hier
vorgestellt habe denn ich wollte dass
hier hochziehen hochziehen zack zack
zack zack zack zack und dann lassen wir
hier zwei frei für einen fenster habe
ich habe vorhin schon gesagt so hier
nochmal einen hoch gehen nochmal einen
freilassen für ein fenster an der seite
hier hoch und dann kann ich das hier
generell alles mal so ein bisschen
hochziehen eben da dann mehr kann ich
jetzt gerade mal nicht machen da seht
ihr nämlich schon wie viel quasi
wirklich benötigen also stellt euch auf
jeden fall darauf ein dass wir in
nächster zeit noch ein sehr sehr häufig
in den neckar müssen und die viele meter
im letzten sehen werden ist die flipper
nächste nicht flipper man wieso habe ich
dann zum delfin namens stücken geben und
jetzt sehe ich dann nie wieder
ist ja auch beruf so hier vorne geht gar
nix mehr hier kann ich noch so ein
bisschen lattenkreuz auf jeden fall
mitnehmen ich kann mich dann auf jeden
fall auch schon mal zeigen was ich mit
der glasscheibe machen wollte und zwar
wird das hier noch hochgezogen das ist
auch so eine art stützpfeiler und dann
kommen hier ein
23 hier vorne kommen dann glatze quartz
stufen ich hoffe ich habe die mit
bindung ja genau die sind hier
allerdings brauchen wir davon noch ein
paar mehr habe ich auch noch quasi
blöcke das heißt hatte ich auch auf
jeden fall noch mal bei mehreren
vielleicht schaffen wir dann doch noch
ein bisschen mehr
wir brauchen auf jeden fall noch ein
paar mehr stufen genau die nehme ich
jetzt einfach mal und packe die hier
vorne dran hier brauchen wir jetzt
nämlich vier quarz stufen das wird der
abgang zu unserem pool sag ich mal sein
und dann kommen hier auch wieder
schwarze glasscheiben hin ich mach das
mal ganz gut in das heimnetz und zwar
soll dieser hellgraue trocken beton der
boden von unserem gebäude sein dass ich
eigentlich ganz schön weil das sieht so
ein bisschen aus wie sollen leichter
teppichboden könnte aber auch in die
richtung parkett gehen ich weise sie
nicht holz wenn ich jetzt so ein
bisschen unangebracht hier nicht mal
ganz glatten quartz verpackt in hierhin
das ist dann so auf jeden fall der
eingang dann kommt dann hier so rein
dass sie wird natürlich alles noch
schöner und dann ist das hier quasi der
boden der überall ist hier haben wir
dann auch so schwartze getönte
glasscheiben die sind auch hier vorne
da muss ich das dach dann auf jeden fall
noch überziehen die quarzwerke sind
jetzt auch ein bisschen fertig das heißt
ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen was hier hochziehen können
an den decken allerdings möchte ich an
der stelle ich heute gab die sodann auch
beenden ich hab doch ganz ganz viel auf
meiner liste was ich noch machen wollte
und zwar zum beispiel noch lampen
anbringen ich hatte mir auch eigentlich
aufgeschrieben dass sich die küche
bereits machen wollte allerdings hat sie
jetzt so lange im netter gedauert mit
dem weg nach hause suchen und vor allem
auch mit den ganzen quatsch was
wiedergefunden haben das war echt eine
menge wir brauchen allerdings noch
deutlich mehr weshalb die folge jetzt
wirklich schon beim fast schon wieder
zwei stunden bei mir in der hohe
aufnahme hier ist und wie bereits vorhin
schon gesagt meine handwerker kommen
hier gleich um ich habe probleme mit der
klingelanlage von 1 meine lieben freunde
wenn es euch heute gefallen hat und
hoffentlich keine fans gern probleme am
start waren anlass gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video her da
falls sie noch kein teil der lupo seid
dann abonniert gern mal einen kanal das
würde mich sehr freuen wenn ich schon
seit den kickern auf die glocke dann
könnt ihr die nächste videos nicht mehr
verpassen und bekommt eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich was neues
hochladen
ich lass mich hier gerade schon die
ganze zeit ein bisschen ablenken und ich
sollte jetzt glaube ich einfach mal das
ganze hier beenden
denn wir sind auf jeden fall ein
bisschen weiter gekommen sowie das alles
hier aus sehen die sonne geht unter
davon ist auch ein tintenfisch und der
die letzten worte perfekt
[Musik]